ça c'est pour le mieux
destins sont liés on est là on poussera
pas de là maintenant qu'on y est
[Musique]
bienvenue pour ce nouveau numéro d'
enquête de région ici à paris devant le
palais de l'elysée l'un des symboles de
notre république
le locataire depuis un an s'appelle
emmanuel macron le 7 mai 2010 est à 39
ans il est élu président de la
république le plus jeune de l'histoire
de france
en bouleversant considérablement
l'échiquier politique et en promettant
de transformer les pratiques politiques
aujourd'hui un an après où en
sommes-nous qu'en pensent ceux qui ont
choisi il ya un an de le soutenir mais
aussi ses principaux opposants
la vie politique est celle des français
ont elles véritablement commencé à
changer
il était le premier parlementaire de
droite à rejoindre emmanuel macron
pendant la campagne présidentielle comme
en a 40 ans jean-baptiste lemoyne at il
a atterri au quai d'orsay en tant que
secrétaire d'état quelles sont ses
missions regret que ses choix je kiffe
c'est très intéressant
annie genevard députés l ère du doubs et
martial bourquin sénateur ps du doubs
juge très sévèrement cette première
année des manuels macron à l'elysée
selon eux il est beaucoup trop
autoritaire et très antiparlementaire
faire une loi simplement de la réflexion
de la discussion du débat il n'aime pas
la discussion
un an après l'arrivée du nouveau
gouvernement comment voit-on l'avenir
dans deux petites villes de
franche-comté luxeuil les bains et
l'eures
en créant de l'activité économique ou en
se mobilisant pour les services publics
certains refusent de se laisser gagner
par le blues de la france dit
périphériques
je suis entouré le nombre d'entreprises
sous traitantes vous permettent de le
dépanner en mécanique en électricité
ce sont des gens très compétents dans la
nouvelle assemblée élue l'année dernière
4 124 députés le devenait pour la
première fois c'est le cas du député de
la première circonscription de
saône-et-loire benjamin dirks comme les
autres membres de son parti il voulait
changer la pratique politique alors onze
mois plus tard qu'en est il j'ai
toujours géré quelque part la faune en
fait je crois vraiment ce qu'on fait en
autres
dans notre projet macron un an après
c'est tout de suite dans 4 de région
[Musique]
pour débuter cette émission on va suivre
un bourguignon au quai d'orsay le
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre des
affaires étrangères est encore un
inconnu du grand public pourtant le
jeune sénateur de l'yonne jean baptiste
lemoyne a été le premier parlementaire
de droite à soutenir
emmanuel macron pendant la campagne à
l'élection présidentielle alors comment
at il atterri au quai d'orsay
ce pari risqué à l'époque qui s'avère
désormais gagnant lui réussit il
toujours
c'est ce que nous allons voir nous
l'avons suivi président depuis dix mois
c'est l'une des voix de droite du
gouvernement on a un débat au parlement
qui tombe là le 4 avril à saisir en
plein milieu du séjour prévisionnel et
je dois représenter gouvernement pour
répondre aux parlementaires un
bourguignon sous les ors de la
république
il faut pas s'arrêter à ça on est là
pour travailler on n'est pas là pour
juste rester des étoiles dans les yeux
des paillettes qui tranche avec la
lourdeur des dossiers prison a publié
sur le champ international déploie une
énergie considérable et puis avec jean
yves le drian et bien nous appartient le
mettre en musique tout cela je suis
souvent un peu en précurseur aussi pour
préparer en amont un certain nombre de
rendez vous
quel est le secret de cette valeur
montante de la génération macron sachez
qu'il fait une promotion absolue des
terroirs de bourgogne de nos climats etc
et puis et puis fait un très bon boulot
il est très respecté on le voit quand on
se rend à l'étranger on sent tout de
suite quand on arrive que ses homologues
apprécié à l'homme nous avons passé
trois jours aux côtés de jean baptiste
lemoyne trois jours pour comprendre
celui qui est devenu le numéro deux du
quai d'orsay
beaurevoir l'endroit où l'on travaille
au l'on reçoit des délégations
on a toujours naturellement les drapeaux
lorsqu'une délégation étrangère vient on
met le drapeau de son pays également
vous reconnaissez sûrement la marianne
de l'yonne à l'éffigie de christine
lowry c'est le genre sentimental
jean-baptiste lemoyne le genre à
conserver les souvenirs de sa région
donc ce bureau parisien de la saint
vincent
et puis il ya un élément qui me suis
toujours que j'avais au sénat une pièce
d'échec seul homme avait été remis par
des élèves du pôle formation d'auxerre
de la maison de l'entreprise
je me suis attaché
c'est toujours sur le bureau à proximité
chez lui on le voit d'abord que le
visage poupon les sourires de gentil
garçon
le vol pour erevan jeudi 6 du buzzer ou
du 14 heures le décollage de paris à
13h45 d'accord non mais c'était pour
voir s'il y avait quelque chose mais son
entourage est unanime
jean-baptiste lemoyne est un bourreau de
travail qui ne s'arrête jamais 11 avril
en effet moi j'ai l'agenda du ministre
mais ce n'est pas confirmé
je ne sais pas s'il a une méthode c'est
qu'il fait beaucoup de choses il veut
faire beaucoup de choses et que c'est en
perpétuel mouvement
bien plus que le précédent beaucoup plus
car précédent alors vous savez que cette
mappemonde a une particularité c'est
qu'on y voit l'atce la résidence de
françois mitterrand à l'époque mais on y
voit aussi vézelay et donc lionne et la
bourgogne sont là monsieur ministre
aujourd'hui c'est la concrétisation ou
demain sans doute d'une volonté que le
chef de l'état avait annoncé il ya un an
déjà pour villers cotterêts tout à fait
le 17 mai à 40 ans le voilà en première
ligne sont les questions de commerce
extérieur tourisme et francophonie
on est au coeur de ce qu'ils touchent le
quotidien des français la scolarisation
par exemple des français établis hors de
france
on est également au coeur de leur
quotidien à travers les métiers
artisanaux ont fait la promotion de la
gastronomie française donc tout ça ce
sont ce sont les hôtels des restaurants
qui font vivre nos territoires ruraux il
ya du pain sur la planche
mais quelle formidable espoir et quelle
formidable espérance alors on se
retrousse les manches on y va ensemble
un poste qui oblige ce père de deux
enfants à faire des sacrifices
on se console akka technologies avec les
whatsapp et facetime qui permet de
garder le contact avec les enfants
mais c'est vrai qu'à partir du moment où
on m'appelle papa téléphone je me rends
compte que il ya malheureusement ça va
ça induit des sacrifices familiaux
jean-baptiste lemoyne et le premier élu
de droite à avoir rallié emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui ce sacrifice il le fait il
ya un an alors que le bateau les
républicains tangue en pleine affaire
fillon jean baptiste lemoyne claque la
porte de son parti et par soutenir le
futur président
[Musique]
le 2 mars emmanuel macron présente son
projet présidentiel
moi je me souviens je suis dans mon
bureau au sénat et je regarde ça à la
télé et là je me dis et il m'arrive les
mots de la bouche
si tu es honnête avec toi même sa
démarche est intéressante et elle peut
être un pari réussi
le 21 juin 2017 jean baptiste lemoyne
intègre le deuxième gouvernement
d'édouard fini sa mission secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'europe et
des affaires étrangères je savais que la
décision que je prenais d'apporter mon
soutien mais le maquereau me vaudrait
énormément de remarques de critiques
voire d' insulte mais quand on est bien
dans sa tête ça vous savez ça vous
atteint pas donc vous laisser les chiens
aboient la caravane passe
salut camarade paria à droite devrait
bien qu'elle doive être
conviés dans le saint des saints à
surfer sur le ministre tisse sa toile
chez les marcheurs démarche a séduit par
son audace et son sens politique mois de
l'image que j'ai de jean baptiste est
d'abord celui du courage de ses
convictions il a sans doute fait le
constat avant d'autres que les clivages
gauche droite était quelque chose qui
s'amenuise est et qu'il fallait sans
doute sortir de ce clivage un peu
artificiel et il suffit conviction
[Musique]
c'est que depuis le début du mandat de
jean baptiste lemoyne serait vrai qu'ils
ont nouveau chouchou des marcheurs dans
l'yonne marie louise fort et andré
villiers l'ont côtoyé pendant vingt ans
dans les rangs de la droite pour eux
jean baptiste lemoyne est avant tout un
bon stratège
je pense qu'il fait partie de ces jeunes
qui cherchent à trouver une voie
meilleur pour remettre sur les rails le
pays
donc je lui pardonne d'avoir rejoint
d'autant plus qu'il fait une belle
carrière et qu'il est normal à son âge
qu'on ait envie de faire un bon parcours
il ya parfois des positionnements qui
surprennent le fait que jean baptiste
lemoyne et fait ses armes auprès de jean
françois copé
donc quelqu'un qui appartenait à cette
droite quand même très affirmée dont il
s'est affranchi est passé auprès de
françois fillon puis ensuite alain juppé
pour franchir le rubicon et rejoindre
emmanuel macron donc moi j'y vois une
envie de participer à la vie à la vie
politique de son pays de ne pas perdre
de temps lui loin des guéguerres
politiques seraient du côté des gens du
concret ce jour-là à matignon la france
et le luxembourg signent des accords
historiques
aujourd'hui c'est le
c'est le jour j on a préparé sa horde
amont et puis je crois que tout va bien
se passer des semaines de tractations en
coulisses pour aboutir à cette signature
il ya un certain nombre de défis en
commun sur lesquels au début pour y
avoir des différences d'approché il ya
eu d'acte et le fait d'augmenter le
nombre de trains et de rotations entre
la lorraine et le luxembourg
parce que cent mille français vont
travailler au luxembourg et ça pose de
gros problèmes de mobilité et la volonté
des deux gouvernements comme celle des
élus locaux c'est trouver des solutions
concrètes à cette situation de faire en
sorte que la circulation soit plus
fluide depuis un peu plus de dix mois
que je travaille avec jean baptiste je
ne peux que me réjouir que son
enthousiasme de sa force de travail
c'est pas le plus spectaculaire des
postes du gouvernement parce que c'est
un poste qui exige de bouger de bouger
d'expliquer ce qui se passe en france à
nos interlocuteurs étrangers d'être
capable aussi de nourrir l'action du
gouvernement avec les retours de
l'extérieur ça existe beaucoup beaucoup
de disponibilité la diplomatie un
travail de l'ombre et de longue haleine
une tâche parfois ingrate qui n'entame
pas l'enthousiasmé du jeune ministre
je dois dire que
je kiffe c'est très intéressant il ya
vingt ans je m'étais dit que je voulais
présenter les priorités d'orsay pour
être diplomate
tout ça pour dire qu'il ya toujours un
fil dans la vie que ce fils faut jamais
le perdre et que c'est ça qui fait que
vous êtes en accord avec vous même et
est donc bien dans vos baskets
certains critiquent son chemin parfois
tortueux jean-baptiste lemoyne continue
de tracer sa route à sa passion barack
obama ok ok pour des bagarres radio
boguey la gamme tag waka waka waka waka
waka waka waka waka
ok la gamme takeoka
bonjour oui bien merci d'accueillir ici
au scénar vous êtes sénateur la
république en marge de côte-d'or
président du groupe et le mi6 au sénat
et on le dit proche des manuels macron
vous l'acceptez chat
j'accepte même si parfois on considère
que je suis un intime je suis proche des
manuels macron depuis trois ans je
travaille à ses côtés j'ai participé à
toutes les peaux p marc runyan mais je
suis pas c'est à dire un intime des
manières mais je suis très proche de lui
et j'ai la chance de rencontrer souvent
un an après quel bilan vous vous tirez
de ce manque t j'ai vu quelques quelques
mandats défilé cours de ma vie politique
je vois là la vision d'un chef d'état
qui a acquis en un an
depuis un an une reconnaissance et une
autorité internationale il notorité une
reconnaissance européenne et qui sur le
plan français fait ce qu'il a dit on
fait comme on a dit on engage des
réformes et non seulement garage de
réforme mais en plus on assume les
dossiers qu'ils n'avaient pas été
traités par le passé je vous renvoie à
notre dame des landes
je vous renvoie au problème des hôpitaux
jose ont beau problème des universités
auprès de l'apprentissage et de la
formation
tous ces dossiers qui étaient restées en
suspens parce que on n'osait pas faire
de peur de déplaire
la peur de déranger de peur d'avoir des
manifestations et ce gouvernement
s'engage pleinement droit dans ses
bottes dans l'effort pas vraiment
déterminé le mode wrong dans ses bottes
notamment que tu mal utilisé par le
passé et cani qu'elle connotation
défaitiste par ailleurs un mot utilisé
par alain juppé lorsqu'il était premier
ministre confronté à des mouvements
sociaux parce qu'ils réalisaient des
réformes similaires à celles qui est en
train de faire emmanuel macron fille là
non d'abord emmanuel macron a dit
lui-même à l'automne dernier
si dur de le réformer la france figure
de réformer mais ce qui m'a conduit et
moi suivre emmanuel bach
si à la fois l'analyse et la vision
qu'il a des problèmes qu'elles
confortent confronté notre pays et ceux
qui aujourd'hui à nîmes que la force de
la majorité
c'est la conviction et l'absence de
doute nous ne doutons pas que la voie
que nous avons prise est bonne et il
faut surtout pas douter il faut avancer
est-ce que ça n'est pas justement un
reproche qu'on peut faire à emmanuel
macron celui de ne pas douter de ne
jamais douter une semaine affublé
lui-même du surnom de jupiter et
certains comme ici au sénat gérard
larcher lui reproche de ne pas laisser à
cette place au parlement de ne pas
laisser assez de place à la discussion à
la concertation c'est un reproche qui
est assez fréquent le parlement est
parfaitement respectée il ya une
majorité pro macron l'assemblée
nationale il ya une majorité anti macron
ici composite et je crois que les
bagnoles mâcon a su convaincre les
français que si nous ne réparons pas le
pays maintenant
après il serait sans doute trop tard et
personne ne pourrais le faire et il a
tiré de ses deux prédécesseurs en
particulier il a tiré les conséquences
pour la mare ce qu'il advient suivre et
dans le même temps il avait à la fois
annoncer des réformes
les français l'ont entendu votre point
de vue m'intéresse parce que vous êtes
un ancien socialiste
un homme de gauche et vous parlez des
déçus des manuels macron il ya peut-être
là toute une partie de l'électorat des
manuels macron qui venait de la gauche
et qui voit les premières réformes du
quinquennat des réformes classé plutôt à
droite alors quelle est votre vision
vous l'homme de gauche
on va prendre tout simplement les fêtes
si on veut redistribuer
il faut d'abord produire
et si on veut repourvoir redonner du
pouvoir d'achat ont redonné demain du
gain aux salariés il faut que l'économie
aille mieux
dont il n'est pas anormal que les
premières mesures pour redonner de la
croissance à ce pays qui en a plus
aujourd'hui un lieu plus qu'espéré c'est
du bien entendu à la conjoncture
européenne et mondiale
si due aussi à la confiance car redonner
le chef de l'état du gouvernement que
leurs données dans les entreprises
aujourd'hui est-ce que ça n'est pas
quand même aussi le fruit du travail du
gouvernement précédent et de françois
hollande qui vient d'ailleurs de
l'écrire dans un livre et qui ne veut
pas lui qu'on oublie que les réformes
qu'il a faites mais elles portent leurs
fruits c'est normal un tout petit peu
plus tard la seule chose positive qu'a
fait françois hollande d'avoir choisi
emmanuel macron communiste de l'économie
voilà ce que je peux dire aujourd'hui
mais j'ai le temps d'aller manger
soutenons avec jeu d'ailleurs je n'ai
jamais été
frondeur j'ai soutenu le gouvernement je
soutenais surtout les avancées que
poussé emmanuel barron on a déjà entendu
critiquer le bilan de françois hollande
se dit qu'ils étaient frileux mais je
reviens à notre sujet aujourd'hui
redonner de la souplesse au travail
faire que le travail paye mieux c'est
pas une réforme de droite faire que le
travail paye mieux une réforme de gauche
ensuite quand je vois le dédoublement
des classes ça a été la rentrée scolaire
de l'année 2017 a été la rentrée la plus
à gauche qu'on ait vu depuis 12 ans la
suppression partielle d'heuliez sf c'est
quand même une ville au minimum
vieillesse l'immobilier de son héros est
une mesure de gauche
la hausse du salaire pour les salariés
aujourd'hui avec la baisse des
cotisations sociales
l'augmentation de la csg c'est une
maison de croissance donne 5 et vous
m'en donnez une balle à j'en ai déjà
cité de la 2d moi je pense qu'à 5 à 2
ce jugement manichéen simpliste que
j'entends de la bouche de mes amis
socialistes parce que moi je suis resté
savez j'ai toujours été social démocrate
j'étais je suis dans le comme emmanuel
macron d'un fils droite de ce qu'était
mendès-france rocard je passe trop ce
cas après ce premier anniversaire y ait
à la suite du quinquennat avec les
réformes en cours les réformes à venir
qu'on voit dans toutes ces choses que
vous citez qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
travail et il reste encore quatre ans
allait très bien mais il nous a semblé
que y compris au sénat y s'il vous plaît
la ccib la ccib la session parlementaire
du mode du printemps jusqu'à la fin
juillet et très intense autour de
réformes important qu'elle
il ya le la loi logement qui vient il ya
la réforme de l'immigration vient la
formation professionnelle parce que ça
n'est pas aussi un reproche quand même
d'aller trop vite de multiplier les
réformes alors vous me direz si vous
n'aviez rien fait on vous le
reprocherait aussi mais du coup il ya
même des parlementaires de la république
en marge qui dit qu'ils sont épuisés
est ce que ça ne va pas trop vite on
travaille beaucoup là on est prêt prix
c'est vrai qu'on est très présent mais
si nous voulons que les réformes que
nous votons aujourd'hui portent leurs
fruits
ça va pas être en 2018 2019 ce sera
2020-2021 vous a pas échappé que c'est à
la veille de la future présidence y
règne on comprend mais si on ne les fait
pas maintenant c'est à dire aujourd'hui
on n'a pas un rythme appelé
stakhanoviste pour réformer les lois
c'est pas maintenant alors on n'aura
jamais lieu
il faut que les grandes oies que nous
votons aujourd'hui elles toutes été
votées avant le mois de juin à l'année
prochaine
donc françois patriat si je comprends
bien rendez vous dans quatre ans pour
voir si tout cela est bien arrivé merci
nous avoir fait partager votre vision de
cette première année du quinquennat d'
emmanuel macron et de nous avoir
accueillis ici au sénat remercie merci à
vous merci beaucoup
il y a les soutiens bien sûr et puis il
ya aussi les opposants comment juge-t-il
sept premières années du quinquennat
macron une de nos équipes a suivi deux
parlementaires l'une de droite l'autre
de gauche
annie genevard députés les républicains
du doubs et secrétaire général du parti
les républicains et martial bourquin
sénateur socialiste du doubs ils nous
livrent leur vision de sept premières
années de quinquennat
[Musique]
regardez c'est super le 19 juin dernier
annie genevard des républicains est
réélu député
c'était un super moment de la 5e
circonscription du doubs celle de
pontarlier morteau comme un soulagement
la droite très implanté dans les zones
rurales de franche-comté résiste bien à
la vague macro nist d'ailleurs la
défense de la ruralité c'est maintenant
l'un des chevaux de bataille des
républicains
ici aux bréseux l'école vient d'être
sauvé de la fermeture grâce à la
mobilisation des parents et des élus ce
qui était un peu original quand même la
situation des bréseux c'est que c'était
pas seulement des suppressions de
classes c'était une suppression des cols
c'est quand même pas la même chose
et puis je pense que votre mobilisation
elle a été utile aussi bon jour
[Musique]
donc on a déménagé la mairie en face et
on a créé l'ouverture là pour permettre
l'accès depuis la salle de classe à ce
stade et motricité suffit salle de
sieste pour accueillir les trois ans et
puis permettre de sauver notre école on
l'a presque admis comme une fatalité
la campagne se vide de ses commerces de
ses services de ces écoles on nous dit
même maintenant il ya trop de communes
trop d'élus la mairie et le dernier
services publics dans les campagnes
le socialiste martial bourquin et
sénateur du doubs depuis 2008
ils seront ici dans un ehpad pour parler
des conditions de travail des personnels
et de vie des résidents moi je vous
donne juste un exemple l'après midi j'ai
trois aides soignantes pour 89 président
en cours et bien être à peu près dans
les cordes il faudrait qu'on vient au
lieu de trois avait il faudrait il
faudrait quasiment le double double de
tous le parlementaire est bien conscient
du manque de moyens pour les personnes
âgées
il y manque de personnel il ya besoin de
personnel qualifié
lorsqu'on est avec madame bové nous
attire notre attention sur le fait qu'il
faut une politique nationale annie
genevard se préoccupe de la
désertification des centres villes même
si son secteur l'aude ou frontaliers au
fort pouvoir d'achat souffrent moins
qu'ailleurs
elle a proposé à bruno le maire le
ministre d'économie que les commerçants
soient consultés pour tout projet dans
une zone commerciale de leur ville
mais tous ensuite quand même de chiffres
plus ou moins importants mais quand même
pousse ensuite on met pas les bras parce
qu'on dit des horreurs
on y croit ne continue et on a des
belles boutiques on a des bons produits
voilà dans toutes les boutiques à d
accueil chaleureux je me dis voilà on a
un potentiel
j'ai croisé bruno le maire la semaine
dernière dans les couloirs de
l'assemblée
et je lui ai parlé de salé il m'a dit
c'est une bonne idée donc on va voir
s'il s'en saisit de façon à ce que vous
les commerçants vous puissiez être
consultées chaque fois qu'il ya un
projet d'innovation dans les zones
c'est avec sylvie dallaire présidente
des commerçants de pontarlier qu annie
genevard a été reçue au ministère de
l'économie les zones commerciales sont
exponentielles le centre-ville non le
porte-monnaie des clients non plus donc
aujourd'hui on se trouve face à un
problème qu'on n'arrive pas à résoudre
bruno le maire -ministre d'emmanuel
macron est un ancien cadre des
républicains alors sans rancune je pense
qu'il faut pas être dogmatique
quand on est sur des questions qui sont
pas strictement politique politicienne
après la politique elle a ses droits
c'est normal une bonne démocratie c'est
une démocratie qui fait fonctionner le
débat politique
mais il ya aussi et heureusement des
domaines où on peut travailler ensemble
parce que sinon ce serait à désespérer
vous êtes presque devenu macro nist et
pas du tout alors moi j'aimais je vous
rassure je ne le suis pas du tout parce
que voilà
moi j'aime les choix clair
elle n'était pas ma chronique elle ne
l'est pas devenu martial burqa non plus
chargé d'une mission sur alstom et les
filières industrielles
il rencontre les salariés de peugeot
japy leur site a été longtemps menacé
on est en plein dans les ordonnances
macro reçoit c'est à dire un moment
donné ils nous disent pour être
concurrentiels faut baisser le coût du
travail est arrivé à ce qu'on ait une
industrie beaucoup plus performante
c'est toujours plus pour les salariés
on leur demande toujours plus par contre
on leur donne toujours moins et on leur
dit soyez content parce que vous aurez
votre emploi là vous garderez vous c'est
toujours la même chose de chantage à
l'emploi
voilà selon vous macro et davantage
financier que industrielle commune comme
culture indubitablement oui il y a alors
bien sûr on doit toujours regarder
l'aspect financier des choses mais
l'industrie c'est du court moyen long
terme
et aujourd'hui on est dans le court
terme et surtout l'industrie c'est un
projet c'est une ambition c'est une
vision je la cherche vainement cette
vision je ne la trouve pas ces manuels
match emmanuel macron je me lâche je la
cherche notre lune à droite l'autre à
gauche
et pourtant ces deux parlementaires
porte le même regard sur emmanuel macron
et sa pratique du pouvoir
je pense qu'il y a chez cet homme
quelque chose d'assez très autoritaire
et moi je suis effaré je vous le dis je
suis effaré de voir le sort qui est fait
aux parlementaires pensent qu emmanuel
macron un problème avec le parlement il
n'aime pas la discussion
ils veulent diriger la france comme on
dirige une entreprise le monde de
l'entreprise seulement de l'économie qui
suppose la rapidité des prises de
décision selon des modalités
particulières mais le monde politique
est un autre monde
il peut faire une loi ça demande de la
réflexion de la discussion du débat dans
ces temps normal donc du temps et le
contrôle de l'exécutif c'est parlement
qui doit avoir des pouvoirs qui doit re
le temps de légiférer
on va réduire le temps de débat sur la
semaine on va réduire la session
parlementaire
on va plus faire de séance de nuit on va
réduire le nombre de parlementaires on
va introduire de la proportionnelle on
va légiférer par ordonnance quand vous
mettez ça boutabout vous composez un
paysage et cerise sur le gâteau les
partis ne servent plus à rien vous
proposez un paysage qui interroge sur le
plan de la conception plus présent de la
république se fait de la démocratie
il ya eu des illusions sur sept
personnes des illusions ou des officiers
ou la désillusion non attaché c'est à
dire à un moment donné des personnes ce
sont des bas pourquoi pas il est jeune
il a il a envie bah on va voir un an
après le constat est amer
[Musique]
loin d'ici loin de paris il y à une
france qui a peur du déclassement cette
france et celle des champs bien sûr mais
aussi celle des petites villes qui
considère souvent qu'elles sont oubliés
par le gouvernement un an après
l'arrivée du nouveau président de la
république on s'est rendu en haute saône
entre lure et luxeuil les bains deux
villes de moins de 10000 habitants où on
refuse de se laisser gagner par le blues
de la france dit périphériques là aux
portes de la ville
c'est un peu la rivière des sans-souci
l'image même d'une france paisible et
presque chanceuse
enfin c'est ce que croit ceux qui ne
vivent pas car non loin de ce cours
d'eau
il y à d'autres lieux encore plus
paisible et qui visiblement ont un
problème avec le 21e siècle
pour découvrir la france des petites
villes en 2018
il vaut mieux avoir le permis et garder
un oeil sur le compteur allure la cité
du sapeur camember comme à
luxeuil-les-bains réputé pour ces termes
nous sommes allés à la rencontre de ceux
qui se retroussent les manches pour que
lors de ville retrouve des couleurs
c'est le cas de stéphane boulanger les
commerces des erp les centres-villes et
bien lui il a décidé de s'y installer
tout n'a voulu me dissuader même c'est
je pense qu à part moi et mon banquier
mon avis personne n'y croyait à cette
histoire donc donc mon nom c'était le
principal il ya quand même des choses
qui bougent c'est vrai que l'udc
salutations ville était tombée très bas
il suffit de se promener dans la rue
principale pour voir les les vitrines à
vendre donc mais non ça oui a pas de
raison ça a l'air de vouloir dynamiser
un petit peu il ya des gens qui ont
l'air de d'avoir envie que ça bouge quoi
donc on verra
s'intéresser à l'urée à luxeuil n'est
pas vraiment un hasard
ces deux petites agglomérations de
haute-saône presque voisine font
régulièrement l'actualité en raison des
difficultés qu'elles rencontrent et des
services publics qu'elle voit partir
culte encore hamas d coup derrière les
oreilles bon
on se dira quoi bon à quoi bon mais
c'est toujours bon jour bon de montrer
les dents puis de montrer qu'on n'est
pas on n'est pas une réserve d'indiens
ici quoi faut arrêter pour ces militants
syndicaux la situation pourrait même
empirer avec l'actuel gouvernement
là on va saint sauveur donc le petit
village qui a juste à côté au bout de la
ligne droite qui colle à luxeuil où il y
avait un
où il y avait un bureau de poste entre
guillemets de plein exercice où il y
avait des gens qui travaillaient où il y
avait des zones d'instance des postiers
qui ne se lasse jamais de vous montrer
les conséquences de ce management de la
fermeture faut pas oublier que le
citoyen y les contribuables il est les
deux en retour s'ils participent à la
collecte fiscale c'est qu'en retour il
est censé avoir je sais pas une école
pas trop loin un service un service de
santé pas trop loin une gendarmerie
présente pas trop loin puis au moins à
merde son bureau de poste pas trop loin
mais certains ont décidé de ne pas se
laisser faire
michel antony est à la tête d'un comité
de vigilance pour le maintien des
services publics allure par exemple
l'état décidé de fermer la prison jugés
trop vétustes
la population s'est alors mobilisée et
le gouvernement à premier la
construction d'une nouvelle maison
d'arrêt services publics la maison
d'arrêt ce service public aussi quoi
c'est pas celui qu'on préférait
conserver il vous préférez des trains en
permanence on préférera des écoles plus
nombreuses vous préférez des urgences
pièce mur mais bon une maison d'arrêt ça
fait aussi partie de notre quotidien
c'est du boulot c'est les gens qui
travaillent c'est des gens qui font un
temps de peine qui ont droit aussi l
proches de leurs amis leurs parents
leurs copains pour cet historien
spécialiste des huttes au pied de
l'autogestion ce qui ne donne pas de la
voix ne sauveront rien de leur
territoire pour lui ces mêmes
aujourd'hui un choix de société
même les élus les plus favorables à la
reconversion
deux territoires à la concentration la
métropolisation ils se rendent compte
que leur territoire disparaît que leur
petite cité disparaître et quand on
ferme les petites localités ici qu'est
ce qui se passe va les gens sur les
grandes et grands qui sont saturés
on ferme une urgence ici on a des
urgences saturé à besançon qu'il ya des
gens donc ces imbéciles cesse des
positions qui sont qui sont en dehors de
tout bon sens les élus de terrain
justement qui doivent souvent faire plus
avec moins
sont ils toujours gagné par la déprime
ou contraire va-t-il enfin l' avenir
s'éclaircir à luxeuil
on préfère s'appuyer sur le dynamisme
retrouvé de cette petite zone
industrielle pour combattre une idée
reçue celle du sauve-qui-peut
typiquement une entreprise là mais neil
qui est là depuis le début
qui a cru nos territoires et qui rentra
maintenant de construire ce bâtiment
juste à côté
si ça ne va pas très fort du côté des
emplois publics
ça n'empêche pas la reprise des
investissements privés
on commence à avoir les avantages de nos
inconvénient c'est à dire que on a des
bâtiments disponibles
on a une offre immobilière accessible et
aujourd'hui on pourrait imaginer une
politique audacieuse au niveau de l'état
consistant à réinvestir sur le monde
rural
parce qu'il n'ya pas le problème de
stationnement comme il ya dans les
grands pôles urbains ya pas le problème
du prix de l'immobilier y a pas tout ça
je suis très optimiste dans cette région
située au pied des vosges il vit enfin
une activité économique qui demeure à un
bon baromètre du business local la syrie
gionet existe depuis des décennies
ce n'est pas la fermeture d'un bureau de
poste qui peut faire trébucher le 6
heures non ce sont plutôt les règles du
marché
on a une des premières forêts d'europe
mais notre balance notre balance
commerciale sur les produits forestiers
elle est négative on exporte plus de
produits et puis on va ré importé du
meuble la belgique l'italie
nous exportons du meuble ça on pourrait
savoir faire en france et il ya encore
des fabricants qu'ils savent faire parce
qu'ils sont modernisés un patron qui ne
s'inquiète pas trop pour l'avenir car
ici plus qu'ailleurs on peut compter sur
des salariés attachés à leur territoire
vous avez le père qui travaille ici qui
fait rentrer son fils son neveu âgé
vraiment est issu de gens très sérieux
et je suis entouré de tout 1 2 de
nombreuses entreprises sous traitantes
qui me permettent de me dépanner en
mécanique en électricité et ce sont des
gens très compétents
donc moi je vois pas pourquoi on ne
pourrait pas continuer à se développer
ici
dans cette france de l'est à l'écart des
métropoles régionales
on hésite encore à miser sur des matins
ensoleillés
un an après l'arrivée d' emmanuel macron
certains évoquent une atmosphère
positive mais d'autres des combats à
venir contre la vitesse à 80 km heure
par exemple
une mesure qui symbolise elle aussi la
fracture territoriale
[Musique]
vous n'avez pas
ça
serap
bonjour martial foucault bonjour merci
nous accueillir ici au cevipof le centre
d'étude de la vie politique qui dépend
de sciences pour à sciences po paris
vous êtes je sais un peu bourguignon
quand même dans l'âme mais parisien par
la force des choses on s'interroge sur
cette première année d emmanuel macron à
la présidence de la république
il avait promis comme tous les hommes
politiques tout un tas de choses mais sa
première promesse j'ai envie de dire
c'est de bousculer de changer de
transformer la vie politique française
est ce que le pari réussi c'est
effectivement c'était une promesse qu'il
a égrainé pendant de longs mois durant
cette campagne présidentielle un an
après jacques leleu le constat est et
peut être mitigé par ce qui est à la
fois emmanuel macron ah oui certaine
manière un petit peu contribué à
transformer le paysage politique
on a beaucoup de mal aujourd'hui à
savoir qui incarne l'opposition on est
effectivement proche de l'assemblée
nationale et il ya une grande difficulté
à savoir quel est son opposition
principal la france insoumise les
républicains le parti socialiste et même
le front national avec un nombre de
députés très très faibles donc d'une
certaine manière il a bien transformer
l'espace politique mais on ne sait pas
vers quelle forme aujourd'hui cet espace
politique se reconfigure et donc cela a
quand même des conséquences importantes
dans le jeu démocratique français qui a
toujours est habitué depuis plus de 50
ans à avoir une opposition droite contre
gauche à la fois aux positions
partisanes aussi opposition de projet
politique alors emmanuel macron à aa eu
finalement cette certaine manière cette
audace et l'opportunité de dire des c
précisément que cette opposition droite
gauche qui aujourd'hui à contribuer un
peu has a sclérosé le pays a le le
bloquer et donc il a proposé pendant
plusieurs semaines un agenda de réformes
et un an après on est en mesure
d'apprécier à la fois le type de
réformes qui ont été qui ont été engagés
et le constat que l'on peut faire c'est
que globalement ce qu'avait annoncé
emmanuel macron il y a répondu sur des
dimensions économiques et c'est là la
priorité de son agenda législatif
pendant un an et sur les autres
dimensions qui lui avait permis à la
fois d'attirer des électeurs de gauche
des électeurs de droite modérée en
attend toujours un petit peu mais c'est
à dire c'est la dimension tri culturel
ce libéral culturel capable de de dire
aux français
j'ai compris les sources de blocage de
la société et donc je vais libérer sur
le terrain des sujets moreau la question
du logement en fait tout ce qui fait
aussi une dimension redistributive
auxquelles sont attachés des français
est là pour le moment est un peu une
panne
une panne du moteur du réformateur
qu'incarne emmanuel macron donc tout a
été mis sur la dimension économique
il a modifié considérablement la vie
politique parfois en piquant un petit
peu des choses à la droite et des choses
à la gauche en les ans les phagocytes en
prêt et ce cas on le voit bien on voit
bien l'état des républicains aujourd'hui
où l'état du parti socialiste mais tout
cela il a fait presque avant le 7 mai
dernier
depuis finalement les choses sont assez
calme assez posé notamment grâce à sa
majorité pléthorique
alors oui il a il a créé une disruption
dans le système politique et une
disruption ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que il a tout simplement
transformer le jeu des clivages
politiques
et si aujourd'hui vous vous avez raison
de dire que on voit pas bien encore
comment tout cela se remet en place mais
c'est qu'on est encore au coeur du
tremblement et il est totalement
surprenant d'observer que ni la droite
classique ni la gauche classique n'ont
pas réussi à trouver
finalement les points d'accrochage pour
essayer d'affaiblir
emmanuel macron affaiblir le président
mais aussi affaiblir son gouvernement
parce que ce qui a surpris les français
depuis le 7 mai c'est la capacité avec
quelle vitesse et même accro à incarner
la fonction présidentielle et c'est vrai
que beaucoup d'observateurs n'avait pas
anticipé cette faculté qu'il a eu à
incarner les toffes d'un président il a
endossé presque trop vite en tous les
cas très vite ce costume de président de
la vème république deux présidents
finalement qu'ils dirigent
moi je pense que c'est une vraie
revanche de la 5e république quand la
vème république est née général de
gaulle avait quand même des craintes
très très forte vis-à-vis des partis
politiques
or là on voit emmanuel macron sans parti
politique quasiment alors on parlera de
mouvement c'est des éléments de
rhétorique je pense sans parti politique
accéder aux plus hautes fonctions de
cette 5ème république donc c'est une
véritable revanche des institutions pour
installer un président en dehors des
partis de la mouvance de l'institution
où c'est l'effet quinquennat aussi je
crois que c'est avant tout
la grande capacité d' emmanuel macron à
ceux associés à s'encastrer dans le
cadre institutionnel
on voit qu'on est quand même encore dans
une logique très verticale il y a un
agenda définie par le président qui
passe en conseil des ministres et les
députés ont très très peu de pouvoir de
modifier le dire ça a toujours été comme
ça sous la 5ème et la sacem changea
devait changer ça vous fait partie des
premières réalité du jeu parlementaires
montrent que les institutions elles sont
faites et on ne bouscule pas les
institutions aussi facilement pour aller
à un tout petit peu plus loin et
peut-être pour conclure martial foucault
emmanuel macron a changé une certaine
forme de vie politique ce jeune
président avec son mouvement la
république en marche ses députés très
nombreux à l'assemblée aujourd'hui il va
durer dans la vie politique française où
est-ce qu'on est dans une
dans une séquence qui n'aura peut-être
pas un avenir très très long elle si on
doit se farcir doit se projeter sur les
quatre prochaines années je prends cette
période en me disant quatre ans avant
l'arrivée au pouvoir des manuels macron
qui connaissait emmanuel macron qui
avait imaginé qu'il deviendrait
président donc je dirais que quatre ans
dans l'univers dans les représentations
des manuels macron c'est un temps
indéfini
c'est très très long aujourd'hui je
crois que la durée la longévité des
macros com
comme président et sa cape est la
capacité de son mouvement politique à
s'imposer en france fait principalement
dépendent comme chaque président de la
vème république
comment peut-il contourner et anticiper
l'usure du pouvoir
je crois que ça c'est l'eau finalement
c'est le fléau auquel tous les
présidents sont sont exposés et puis
deuxièmement est-ce qu'il balaie encore
plus loin dans cette disruption du
système politique va-t-il continuer pour
les prochaines élections européennes a
essayé de débaucher des responsables
politiques à droite à gauche
quel type d'alliance peut-il nous et
lors des élections locales les élections
municipales
on sait qu'aujourd'hui son mouvement
manque d'ancrage et très très bas voilà
très très peu représentées il n'y a pas
ce maillage territorial
on sait que ça prend beaucoup de temps
pour installer un parti politique à
l'échelon local
donc est ce qu'ils se projettent dans
une ambition non pas personnelle mais
une ambition politique à tous les
niveaux de gouvernement en france auquel
cas
donnons nous rendez vous dans dix ans et
on fera le bilan aujourd'hui c'est
beaucoup trop tôt ou bien est-ce qu
emmanuel macron ne leur a pas réussi à
mettre en difficulté comme il le fait
aujourd'hui à la fois les républicains
et le parti socialiste et même d'une
certaine manière la france en soumises
pour lui assurer un boulevard sans
opposition mais est ce que au fond peut
s'interroger est ce que le bon
fonctionnement d'une démocratie c'est
précisément de ne pas avoir de position
je crois que tous les exemples de pays
qui ont vu l'opposition cadenassé pour
de bonnes ou de mauvaises raisons par
les modifications des règles du jeu
institutionnel sont des pays qui ont
connu des épisodes extrêmement
douloureux pour les peuples
donc je pense que manuel macron joue sur
un terrain extrêmement compliquée qui
est faire vivre une démocratie en
changeant les règles à la marge les
règles du jeu mais en essayant de ne pas
être sans opposition parce que pas
d'opposition veut dire une démocratie
extrêmement affaibli
on le sait très bien l'opposition
ensuite arrive à l'intérieur même de la
majorité c'est ça ça peut arriver et
c'est déjà arrivé j'ai bien c'est
compris le message rendez vous dans dix
ans partir pour commercy se venge des
explications merci à très bientôt
or
[Musique]
dans la nouvelle assemblée élue l'année
dernière 4 124 députés le devenait pour
la première fois renouvellement inédit
dans l'histoire de la vème république un
phénomène en partie due au succès du
mouvement créé par emmanuel macron la
république en marche parmi ces nouveaux
députés celui de la première
circonscription de saône-et-loire
benjamin dirks cet entrepreneur de 38
ans en portait sa première élection
politique
le 18 juin dernier comme beaucoup des
membres de son parti il souhaitait
changer les pratiques de la vie
politique alors onze mois plus tard
qu'en est il nous l'avons suivi en juin
dernier il poussait les portes du
prestigieux palais bourbon pour la
première fois un an plus tard il tente
de garder la tête froide
en fait j'ai pris ça depuis le premier
jour comme un lieu de travail
et donc je me suis tout de suite
projetés dans un lieu de travail et pas
ne pas sentir ce poids je ressens
effectivement la responsabilité mais le
poids de l'histoire je vais occulter
quelques passements à 39 ans bazana dire
qui fait partie de cette nouvelle
génération qui souhaite transformer la
politique vers des pratiques plus
pragmatique et moins idéologique un
entrepreneur devenu élu de la nation
vous vous êtes venu vraiment
spécialement pour l'entreprise pour cet
emploi c'était d'abord six mois à
shanghai est lundi aux circonscriptions
en visite dans cette entreprise
mâconnaise le député est comme un
poisson dans l'eau
quelque chose qu'on quand même bien que
cérémonie du prince sprint en fait tous
les développeurs supprime gidding pics
de charge ou encore développement agile
un jargon familier pour lui l'été
dernier il a fermé son entreprise de
formation pour se consacrer entièrement
à son mandat de député sont passés de
dirigeant est ici un atout certain
forcément que ce que semaine et qu'il ya
des choses que je ressens que j'ai déjà
que j'ai déjà vécu une personne de
terrain qui a un regard neuf
ça peut faire avancer beaucoup plus vite
les choses qu'une personne qui peut-être
dans un sérail depuis très longtemps
direction ensuite sa permanence
parlementaire pour ce qu'il appelle les
états généraux de la ville et du pain
son idée réunir chaque semaine les
professionnels du secteur viticole
autour d'une thématique l'atelier du
jour est consacré aux formations avec le
directeur du lycée de davayé au moins
dire après on a un panel de formations
qui sont des formations courtes type
taille de la vigne
l'objectif c'est d'avoir et ben je pense
aller 70 80 % des choses qui pourront se
faire au niveau local juste le fait
d'avoir tout le monde réuni ce qui ne se
fait pas habituellement
et puis si on doit réussi à aller
jusqu'à légiférer sur certaines choses
aujourd'hui on est au moment des états
généraux de l'alimentation de la
présentation de la loi qui va arriver
et ben pourquoi pas pouvoir amender la
loi sur certains sur certains points
pour nous ce qui est nouveau c'est de la
proche du terrain d'être d'être d'être
plus ou moins représentées et de pouvoir
discuter les choses franchement vous
avez une région que qu'avant c'était
moins que là bas je pense qu'on était un
peu plus éloigné du terrain
avant la république en marche bazana
dire qu'il n'avait jamais adhéré à aucun
parti politique
aux législatives de 2007 il est désigné
pour représenter le mouvement
il part à la conquête du siège du temps
mais alors par thomas thévenoud et au
second tour
il s'impose face au très expérimenté
maire de mâcon tout sépare la vague
macro et sa promesse de renouveau
je pense que la politique n'est pas un
métier on se met on s'engage c'est pas
évident de s'engager quand on vient de
la société civile c'est au delà des
efforts c'est qu'on sait très bien que
les problématiques que ça peut engendrer
pour un chef d'entreprise on peut
l'imaginer quand il reviendra après dans
le monde dans le monde privé
aujourd'hui ça dix partagent entre le
travail en circonscription et celui à
l'assemblée le train du lundi soir pour
paris est déjà presque une routine
malgré son manque d'expérience dans la
fonction l'homme pense avoir trouvé ses
marques
c'est dur de dur de juger je sais pas si
ça vaut deux
un mois de faire moi ce que je sais
c'est que je donne mon maximum tous les
jours que
voilà que je compte ni mon papa du tout
mon temps et que j'ai toujours géré à
quelque part là faut en fait je crois
vraiment ce qu'on fait je prends notre
en notre projet aujourd'hui au niveau
national ont quand même
que la france se redresse et
les chiffres de la croissance de
l'emploi la baisse de la dette jeu très
importante qui du concret aussi qu'on a
pu avoir sur le territoire n'est cité
judiciaire ça fait dix ans qu'on
attendait ça mc on a pu la voir mon
travail était là pour beaucoup une
gendarmerie qui va être construite il ya
plein de projets comme ça
bonjour bien viens dans mon bureau
parisien
la chance d'avoir deux bureaux séparés
ce qui n'est pas le cas de tous les
députés sur paris je peux avoir c'est
ici que le parlementaire prépare le
travail législatif ses interventions
dans l'hémicycle ou en commission par
rapport aux communes nouvelles
je pense qu'il faudrait ajouter qu
aujourd'hui en fait c'est au delà en
fait des futures élections c'est aussi
les les communes qui hésitent
aujourd'hui a basculé sur des communes
nouvelles parce que peur de la
représentativité de leur commune
d'aujourd'hui pour demain s'agit d'un
outil très important pour les
collectivités
un travail mythos lumière lorsqu'il
abouti à une question orale au
gouvernement
cette situation est particulièrement
intolérables s'agissant de plateformes
kermiyan big ip y en a pour ridiculement
bas en france alors que votre pays et
son deuxième marché dans un contexte de
défiance vis-à-vis des politiques
des sites internet tentent d'évaluer
leur travail sur des critères
quantitatifs comme le taux de présence
le nombre de rédaction de rapports ou
d'amendements
le plus connu d'entre eux c'est le
classement du magazine capital
un classement peu flatteur pour les
députés la république en marche souvent
en queue de classement
benjamin dire que c'est classé 73e
elle fait ça n'a pas de sens ça n'a pas
de sens puisque on classe en place par
rapport à quoi quand les critères sont
pas les bons voulait classer quoi le
travail quand on aux affaires étrangères
je vous le dis depuis tout à l'heure les
lois ne passe pas par les affaires
étrangères on peut demander à certains
endroits mais les lois ne passe pas par
nous donc forcément on n'a pas le temps
de passage dans l'hémicycle qui permet à
certains d'avoir
d'avoir des points il faut savoir quand
même le petit jeu qui se faisait
notamment avec les anciens députés qui
vont faire une petite interjections
pendant pendant les questions au
gouvernement ou pendant un débat sur une
loi juste pour bien montrer qu'ils sont
dans l'hémicycle et à ce moment là ils
ont un point ce serait bien si c'est ça
le travail d'un député moi c'est pas
bien rester discret et miser sur la
qualité de son travail pour exister
c'est le pari de ce jeune député mais
cela suffit-il dans les rues de mâcon
nous avons présenté son portrait parmi
ceux d'autres personnalités politiques
locales
benjamin dirks député république en
marche du mak ont dit un jour tu
souhaitais apporter connaître non non je
ne connais pas ça va jamais à dire que
c'est votre député super difficile de
marquer clairement un territoire en
seulement une année après des décennies
d'alternance entre la gauche et la
droite traditionnelle
pour benjamin dire et les autres
nouveaux députés du parti des manuels
macron il reste quatre ans pour y
parvenir
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission on
se retrouve très bientôt pour un nouveau
numéro d' enquête de région et d'ici là
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]